N
AND YOU WILL.
"GUTFELD!" NEXT.
>> President Biden: I CAN ONLY
ASSUME THAT YOU WILL ENJOY
EDUCATING YOUR FAMILY ABOUT HOW
THE COAST GUARD IS "THE HARD
NUCLEUS AROUND THE NAVY FORMS IN
TIMES OF WAR."
YOU ARE A REALLY DULL CLASS.
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN, COME ON, MAN, IS THE SON
GETTING TO YOU?
I WOULD THINK YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I SAY THAT
ABOUT THE NAVY CLASS.
>> Greg: TALK ABOUT THE POT
CALLING THE KETTLE SLEEPY.
[APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT!
IF YOU ENTER THE PHRASE "BLUE
LIVES MATTER" INTO GOOGLE,
YOU'LL FIND A LONG LIST OF
ARTICLES EXPLAINING HOW RACIST
IT IS.
I NEVER KNEW THAT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IF THAT 48
OFFICERS WERE SHOT AND KILLED IN
2020 AND THEY DO MATTER.
TO ME AND PROBABLY TO YOU.
OBVIOUSLY TO YOU.
15 WERE ALSO STRUCK DEAD BY CARS
ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD, LIKELY
ASSISTING SOMEONE WHO NEEDED
HELP.
DID YOU KNOW 2020 WAS ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST YEARS FOR COPS EVER?
264 DEATHS FROM NUMEROUS CAUSES.
THE HIGHEST KILLER?
COVID, OBVIOUSLY, BUT YOU DON'T
HEAR ABOUT THIS MUCH.
AND THEY ALSO WONDER HOW MEN AND
MINORITY COPS DIED LAST YEAR,
BUT I PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BRING
THAT UP EITHER SINCE CARING
ABOUT THEIR LIVES, THAT COULD BE
BIGOTED TOO.
SO WHERE DOES THIS DELUSIONAL
NATIONWIDE SMEAR OF A SELFLESS
OCCUPATION LEAD US?
TO SHEER STUPIDITY.
IN A FEW DAYS, THERE'S GOING TO
BE A GAY PRIDE PARADE IN NYC AND
YOU KNOW WHO MAY BE BANNED?
THE COPS.
ACCORDING TO ABC NEWS, THE EVENT
ORGANIZERS ABOUT TO ANNOUNCED
POLICE WILL BE BANNED FROM ALL
PRIDE EVENTS ALL THE WAY UP
THROUGH 2025.
SEEMS KIND OF HARSH, 2025, THE
BIDEN ERA.
MY QUESTION: HOW WILL ANYONE
UPRIGHT KNOW WHO THE REAL COPS
ARE?
TRUST ME -- TRUST ME, I'VE BEEN
TRICKED A FEW TIMES.
[LAUGHTER]
WANTS BY THIS GUY.
THE ORGANIZER ALSO WANTS TO
REDUCE POLICE SECURITY AND
FIRST RESPONDER PRESENCE.
BECAUSE IN LARGE GATHERINGS OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE,
YOU DEFINITELY DON'T NEED THOSE
GUYS.
ALL OF THI